the fight to keep classrooms safe in
this pandemic and the country's second
largest school district is about to set
a major new vaccine precedent the los
angeles unified school district will
vote later today on whether it will
mandate coveted vaccines for all of its
students 12 years old and up now this
measure is expected to pass nationwide
only 37 percent of children ages 12 to
15 are vaccinated and infection rates
among children they're soaring jamie
yukis reports on how the pandemic is
playing out in america's classrooms and
the courtrooms too from california to
florida
los angeles school board members are
making their case for why mandatory
vaccines are the best way forward for
kids
it's the safest way we can get back to
our favorite activities it's the
safest and most responsible thing we can
all do in our school district pending
approval kids 12 and up will only be
allowed to attend in-person classes at
los angeles public schools if they have
a coveted vaccine that's why there isn't
measles and mumps and rubella in our
schools because we vaccinate and we
require it it's a mandate
this is a mandate to save lives but some
parents rallied against school vaccine
mandates over the summer and the
district has been sued over some of its
coveted policies los angeles county has
recorded more than 190 thousand covet
cases in kids 17 and under since the
start of the pandemic and kids are
increasingly a focal point in the battle
against the coronavirus
nationwide more than 252 thousand
children tested positive for covit in
the last week of available data
accounting for more than a quarter of
all new cases i don't know why the mass
have politics around it let the parents
make the decision that's best for their
kids a judge on wednesday said schools
there can issue mass mandates a blow to
republican governor ron desantis the
state is appealing the decision
but kovitt is still in the schools in
miami-dade county alone 13 staffers have
died in the past month from covit
including three teachers and according
to johns hopkins florida recorded more
than 2300 total covet deaths in the past
week higher than any other state in the
nation
the los angeles school district says
there are some exemptions to the mandate
but did not outline exactly what they
are just yet right now l.a schools are
full in-person learning but for parents
wondering about when your kids will need
to be vaccinated students need their
second shot by december 19th to be
eligible for in-person classes in the
next semester tony
it's a big development jamie thank you
very much